[Música]
bueno hoy venimos a buscar ropa porque
de verdad no tenemos
[Música]
bueno es indudable el daño es cierto y
el impacto ambiental que tienen estos
micro basurales en general y en especial
los de residuos textiles para las
comunas donde están ubicados ya estos
micro basurales generan desde cuando
cierto a algunos incidentes de quema lo
que evidentemente produce cierto
contaminación del aire
y efectivamente además también algunos
están ubicados cerca de lugares poblados
[Música]
pero día lamentablemente todavía no
pasamos el punto entonces estamos en
hablar con mejor mundo querer un mejor
mundo pero a la hora de comprar sigo
comprando en lo económico uno salió de
la pandemia y uno va y siguió viendo
conejillo antes en zara h&m fue el
everton de iguanas y tiendas que están
orientadas más al fas falló
y
[Música]